uh let's go next to our caller
from country code 49 country code 49
what's your name
and where are you calling from
hey david my name is corey i'm calling
from well i'm i live in heidelberg
germany but i'm on vacation in methane
germany which is
the northwest corner which is about 10
minutes from the netherlands
right that sounds nice how what's the
situation there from the standpoint of
the virus
i'm actually at a family resort right
now looking at a uh i'm in a sports bar
drinking a beer and i'm looking at
families separated from each other and
uh yeah it's kind of weird because
we decided to take this jump because
we've been stuck in her not really stuck
in our house but you know we've been
playing it safe for
since mid-march since you guys have yeah
and um
yeah we decided to take this do it and
we're here and we you know we're doing
what we can we wear masks where we can
but
you know germany's doing quite well we
only had five i think six deaths
yesterday
and you know that sounds terrible you
know when you say oh i only had five or
six deaths but
you know you know what i'm saying yeah
the u.s had 1300 yesterday so it's a
dramatic difference yeah
right so i i've been listening to you
since the joe rogan class we've been
with joe rogan a couple times and i'm a
big fan since then i'm obsessed with
really
listening with you every day i look at
you guys i jog every day and
just i agree with so much of of your
your energy and your soul and where
you're coming from and i'm so happy that
i got a twitter uh notification today
and i'm on vacation i was like
i gotta call in because it's the first
time i've ever found out when to call
so right really what i wanted to call
what i wanted to tell you was that we're
doing good here
i'm actually going to the netherlands
tomorrow to do some shopping uh
come back across the border there's no
restrictions everything's wide open
we're doing fine here i i don't feel you
know
i'm super nervous about everything uh in
the united states right now
i work for i worked for as a contractor
employee with um
with nato and i and i know i think i
understand your feelings about um
you know the military presence or police
stay across the world
i think i have a pretty unders good
understanding of your take on that
but what what truly got me scared is um
you know obviously that he wins four
more years but it's
i could lose my job over this this whole
thing with
um you know him just being pissed off
with miracles okay i'm gonna take
everybody out because i don't like her
i'm gonna take everybody out of uh
germany puts him in
who knows where he wants to put them i
think it's just available right at this
point
but i've never really understood your
feeling about
nato as a whole you've never really
expressed that i've never really heard
you say it i know that you're against
the quote-unquote police state but how
do you feel about
nato in general i don't have any
particular problem
with the idea of organizations
like nato i think the devil is in the
implementation
but i think in in a theoretical
framework
shared defense agreements are reasonable
they make sense we have an increasingly
globalized world you know we often say
at the country level there are some
problems that are too big for anybody
but government to solve and that's why
libertarian ideas sort of fall short
like there are some things
big regulatory things that you just need
the power of government when you've got
a multi-multi-billion dollar
corporation government is what you need
in order to regulate it and
even beyond that when you have
multinationals
and problems that span across multiple
countries
you need some kind of higher
infrastructure and something nato like
is
fine that doesn't mean i necessarily
agree with everything nato does or every
every one of nato's actions including
you know we could go back to the clinton
era or whatever
but i have no problem with with
frameworks like nato in principle
yeah i think i think i get your feeling
on that it's
it's just for me it's just such a it's
like a
two or three year old tantrum right now
with him
with trump against miracle and that's
what that's what bothers me the most
it's just so petty and yeah there's
issues with nato for sure but
you know i'm married to a german uh lady
and i've been here for 10 years
since 2005 off and on but a total of 10
years and i just bought a house here and
i'm so disgusted with what's happening
stateside
but i'm pretty much making my life here
at this point i was i was ready to move
back
i had all these uh plans to move and
back in 2016.
and then it just it's just my mindset
just completely shifted
and that sadly it shifted we had already
planned on moving back but
um anyways david i'm going to listen to
you every day i hope to continue
conversation with you you're doing great
things
i've turned you on to a bunch of people
keep doing the great work man
all right corey from germany thank you i
appreciate the uh the kind words and the
phone call from germany